[Music]
good morning
gamers god damn it feels good to be back
for those who don't know i've been
on a little break and i've been mainly
just playing minecraft on my off time
so it feels really good to be back from
playing minecraft
to play minecraft
hey remember oh wait now that i don't
have face cam i got to do this
hey remember
remember when i play minecraft
ironically yeah i mean either
yeah anyway we're back yeah so
anyway guys sorry this is annoying uh
i actually learned a lot playing it on
my off time
for those who haven't watched it in live
streams by the way we did 12 hour live
stream trying to build a [ __ ]
meatball and i almost died
my gear is just it's just terrible to be
playing
hardcore on this level with this kind of
gear
it's just not okay so i want to i want
to get my frick chamber back in action
do you guys remember that
[Music]
i want to get it back into gear and to
do so we got to find
a village and uh one thing i learned
while playing minecraft offline is maps
are actually very useful
i never really pri i don't know how i
always play without using maps but
they're very helpful
no one told me god damn it
so we're gonna start off today by
heading out on a little adventure isn't
that right
is he alive he's alive he's fine he's
fine guys
you're good i missed you mate
i missed you how you been mane i missed
you guys too
are they flaunting their asses to me
stop it i've been watching b
stars on netflix and it's just changed
things in me i apologize
so i need to exit this map create a new
map
and i think there's a village somewhere
this way
feels good to be back man god damn it's
time to go to sleep
all right can i sleep yeah again my god
why can't i sleep with my horse jurgen
go to bed you're gonna go to bed now
there you go good boy that's a good is
my
armor not enchanted like what am i doing
why is no one telling me off for this i
can't believe just how much i've been
playing everything wrong
is the map glitched what is this
shouldn't it
point where i'm supposed to go i'm
already out of the map that's what's
happened
okay cool now we can use this map
boom we got a new map looks sick
actually
and we'll upgrade it boom
and let's just try and find a village so
then we can bring back people in boats
i don't think that's too much to ask
what is that is that a swamp
see i haven't even explored my area
i'm so scared of everything in this game
damn it looks good
forgot how good these shaders look like
368 oh [ __ ] god damn it you're again
just go up just go up oh gosh there's so
much water have i been here
uh what is that oh a portal
all right stay away jargon you don't go
near portals remember ah
jesus oh
okay all right i'll take it gold
oh jesus pretty cool area here
i'll remind that what's the coordinates
actually i don't need to cheat now i
have a map all right
there's over here got it we'll bring you
back man
we're gonna be friends trust me this is
good this is good
but i need a village first and foremost
what the f
why is there just a random cigarette in
the sky
oh god i hate riding with a horse in
these areas
parkour here again come on let's get it
show those 360s
he's literally stuck isn't he all right
there we go
my man ah dude it's way too dense
i forgot how fat this guy is well this
is going
fantastic by the way so good
i can't even kill a pig dude
i'm so weak i swear there was a village
here somewhere
come on i need fricking is that a temple
have i explored that one i don't
remember this looks a bit weird
but i'm just pushing him get your fat
butt over the leg here again
get your blocky ass booty over there
come on
there it is yes i knew i wasn't crazy
yes you're again we're gonna frick
tonight not you and me
of course [ __ ] yeah oh they already have
an enchantment guy
nice what do we got fire protect you're
gonna come to me and you're gonna make a
lot of babies
you understand you're gonna make a lot
of babies for me
gonna make me very happy a very happy
man
all right let's do what our uh
forefathers did
right let's get out of this this is mine
this is also mine i'll grab their beds
okay we need potatoes please tell me
this is [ __ ]
fine oh they got potatoes
yes now we can make them frick the gods
smile upon us
jurgen they will be freaking tonight
it's kind of a small village but we only
need
to to abduct i mean to kidnap i mean to
bring
uh involuntarily to our place but they
will like it
it's not kidnapping if they like it
stockholm syndrome remember
it's a swedish thing they like it right
you'll you'll have a good time
trust me you're going to have a good
time oh my god there's a little baby
you're so ugly you will never win hand
so much face 20 20 [ __ ]
sorry too real all right
oh my god stop you're ugly get a hint
stop you're a child respect
such a peaceful village it's a shame if
uh someone puts them all in a bow
what are the coordinates the whole map
thing uh makes no sense because i
that this is not on the map is it no
god it's like just off
[Music]
if this is the ocean maybe i can just
put him in a boat he's fine
get over it yeah again yo we got in the
desert
what i knew i wasn't crazy all right
we're gonna abduct them like my
forefathers did
in boats okay i need a brick chamber
it'd be cool if they stayed in here
actually maybe i built in the villagers
in the pyramid
now let's go abduct so i mean let's go
kitten i mean let's go
let's go let's just go i'm super excited
for this playthrough there's so much
that i want to do
i hope you guys are ready because it
starts with the freaking chamber
that's where every legendary story
starts everyone knows
this feels like i'm about to lose my
virginity or something i'm so excited
where are they good
good
come on come on for good old time come
on
i know you want to we're going to be
best friends you're going to become the
mother of many children just get in
trust me it's gonna be epic yeah so can
i put a leash on this
i thought i could put a leash all right
well you'll ride with me that's fine
all right there's another one hold on
one second sir
i if i can avoid doing this twice
then i will avoid doing this twice all
right so i can put a leash on a boat
right oh my god i thought you could put
a leash on a boat
do not go in the boat i thought you
could put can
you put a leash on boat minecraft
in bedrock all right you stay in the
boat
you understand me you stay in the boat
all right here we go
are you serious it doesn't float up it
doesn't float up why does he not float
up get in the [ __ ] boat i'll kill you
it doesn't float up i thought boats
float all right fine i'll abduct you i
mean i'll
you'll go with me first here we go it's
working
oh yes we're gonna become friends trust
me
and nothing bad ever happens to my
friends that's the number one rule god
why are you so fat explain this don't
worry about your friends you'll make new
friends
your own children you can be friends
with them how about that trust me you're
gonna be more safe with me
you're really sick what should i name
you
chiquita bonita
[Music]
you look that that's what you look like
dude once you see my landscaping
you're gonna want to stay trust me it's
like five star hotel over here
uh if i can just find my way there and
it's dark
okay i can i can make it back it's fine
this is kind of romantic shikita bonita
ah
beautiful should we kiss in front of the
meatball
shikita bonita i don't have a minecraft
wife you know
i'm just saying all right so that's one
nice how do i get him
up do i have to use redstone ah did he
already pick
chiquita bonita you can't just pick a
job i decide
oh he loves zay look how happy he is
okay
i don't think that's gonna work i cannot
be bothered to build redstone
i think i'll build their little house in
here
if you're wondering why there's water
here uh don't worry because i have no
clue
okay this is gonna be their house so i'm
gonna place this down
and this down in hopes that he will just
go there
that would be the ultimate please go
please go
enjoy your new home that's right he's
going for it
no no no come here no no no wrong way
wrong way please please please please
please
go this way you're going to like it
you're going to like it
you are going on my nerves all right
guess i will have to abduct you chiquita
bonita make this bigger
chiquita bonita look at your house dude
oh my god you're gonna live here you see
this i put lights
i installed lights for you chiquita
bonita yeah you're gonna i think you're
gonna really really like it i'm really
excited about our relationship together
you and me chiquita bonita
so i'm i know you're gonna be lonely
right and i can't be with you
all the time so i'm gonna bring another
one i'll be right back
i'm just gonna close in don't be i'll be
right back
chiquita bonita all right let's go
number two
there's one let's just sneak
he sees me [ __ ] all right here we go he
doesn't see me
he doesn't see me he's just farming he's
just farming he doesn't know he doesn't
know
he doesn't know he missed he's just
farming he doesn't know he doesn't know
he doesn't know
let's go be quiet just be quiet just be
quiet oh there's potatoes
don't worry i'll bring your precious
potatoes let's go don't ask
ask questions later your life belongs to
me now
what's your name chiquito bonito
oh my god is your wife named chiquita
bonita
oh this is great this is gonna work out
great i have a great feeling about this
chiquita bonito
you can forget about your old life
you're all children
your own goals i got you now
you belong to me welcome to the
land of the free i think you'll like it
here
i think you'll find your wife in quite
the predicament
get in he almost went in on his own
volition that must mean he wants it
guys big surprise in here
that's right that's right you two knew
each other right
[Music]
oh he did the little head jig that means
yeah where's your face
where's your [ __ ] oh there you go all
right let me get you guys some new bed
sheets
uh anything else i can do you want the
door open or door
door close okay no problem you guys
catch up
hey we got some new friends all right so
we need three beds
excellent all right so here's one bed
fresh bed sheets yellow very matching
your hat
and there we go okay i'm gonna just
leave you guys alone for a minute and
then i'll come back with the potatoes
with the potatoes this is gonna go great
have they grown we're gonna have to get
some bone meat
have i had my frame there the entire
time there we go
that's better all right which one is the
potatoes
there we go all right let's witness the
miracle of life guys oh they're already
talking
can they see me oh my god this is so
great
okay so we're going to throw the
potatoes on them while they don't notice
[Music]
oh geez what have i done throw potatoes
on him yeah
yeah yeah you feel that side
cute sexy music sexy minecraft music
it's working they must be irish
[Music]
yes oh my god
make the baby make the baby make the
baby yes yes
yes you two you too don't look at me
don't look at me look at cindy bonita
look at punita look at her look at her
look at her she wants you
she wants you she wants you do it i'm
not looking just do it just do it
[Music]
all right let's get one more bed in
let's get one more bedding make another
one make another chad
guys i'm gonna leave you oh look at that
ugly little [ __ ]
i'm gonna make you work until you die
idiot
[Music]
sorry all right great this is a great
start
why is he still a farmer though so i
would like to get
fortune enchantment or mending on
that would just be no just fortune at
the moment would be amazing
an unbreaking i really need i'm breaking
if i can get that then we're gucci
oh that's so [ __ ]
all right fine i'm fishing in my own
swimming pool at this point does it even
work
amazing how we doing in here fellas
why haven't you picked a job yet you're
not a farmer
pick a new job what's going on why isn't
he not picking a job
make another child freak in front of the
child for all i care
what does he think he's a farmer all
right how are we doing in here should
keep that one
why is the baby yes you in
yes this is good make more babies now
okay to make more babies we actually
need a sheep farm all the stuff i should
have done long ago i am now paying the
price for someone needs to pay the price
there we go now i feel a little better
by myself
there used to be sheep on my island but
i killed them all
is that a sheep oh perfect guys
listen up i got a great place back home
you guys i think you guys are really
gonna like just follow me
back oh my god go back
in oh my god i'm building you a house of
freedom
go back in go back in the house of
go back in the house of freedom i go
back in the [ __ ] house
i don't [ __ ] around all right now you
come with me this is freedom god damn it
again the god damn boat god damn it all
right listen up [ __ ]
i will [ __ ] you all right i don't [ __ ]
around
if you don't do what i say there will be
problems you understand me
that's what i thought yeah i think
you'll like it
it's quite contemporary some say what's
that you think it's modern
contemporary it's not modern you [ __ ]
idiot do you know anything about
architecture
don't piss me off twice now get out of
the boat
follow me follow me let me do a tour
that's where the humans live
and they have freaking this is where the
cows live
i think you'll like it what do you think
what do you think about the cows
so i was thinking i'll say i'll hook you
up right here
next to the next to the couch cool so
i'll be right back
and i'm getting your friend
you're gonna die here do you understand
all right
i'm back how was your time alone follow
me
[Music]
oh look they're already making babies
that's excellent
well done guys proud of you i only have
one wheat
so no one gets it because it's more fair
that way
all right let's see if they have grown
up the kids i think it's too early still
but
it's worth a shot yes perfect it worked
excellent pick a new job
looting two ah i want looting three
though
i'm just going to keep doing this until
that bla that's pretty good
until i get what i want is this cheating
this feels like so lame
all right let's make it a little nicer
for the sheep's really quick
i don't know why i said that
unironically i feel disgusting
go back in go back in or i'll kill you
all right it's gonna look nice i think
yeah yeah it's gonna be nice
you guys are gonna love it all right
great start
fantastic start yes
oh oh let me kiss you
oh [ __ ] yeah cool let me get my wallet
mom get my wallet oh that's beautiful
i'm broke aren't i [ __ ] all right we're
gonna need to make them
they need to make more babies that's all
right i'll see you guys in the next
episode we're going to get some more
babies
we're going to get some more boo boos
subscribe to happen what's going to
happen to chiquita bonita and i'll see
you guys tomorrow bro
fist